what we're going to talk about in this
video are the negatives the negatives of
fractional reserve lending and the
biggest negative of fractional reserve
lending and these are all related is
that it's fundamentally unstable unless
you have a lot of engineering on the
part of central banks and governments to
make it more stable but there are kind
of unnatural engineering unnatural
things have to be put in place in order
to make it stable and the reason why I
say it's unstable is because all of
these depositors have been promised that
their money is safe and sound that it's
being that at any point they can come to
the bank and get their money it's on
demand but a good fraction of that money
is being lent out and you can imagine
let's say that all of these banks are
lending out the money responsibly but
let's say this Bank something shady
happens it lends out money in a really
bad way and it doesn't get it back or
maybe it's even worse maybe there's some
type of fraud taking place where
executives were embezzling money or
whatever these are good actors within a
fractional reserve lending system this
is a bad actor it made a bad loan and
now all of a sudden this money is gone
if you don't have any support from
central banks or from governments now
all of these customers are going to say
wait I heard something shady happened at
this Bank and they're all going to show
up at this Bank they're going to show up
at this Bank all on the same day and
they're going to say give us back our
money and then it'll be pretty clear
that their money actually was not
available that it was lent out some of
it was lost and so they will be very
upset these people right over here and
it's not just bad for this bank it's not
just bad for this Bank and this Bank
might have it doesn't even have to be
that this Bank actually did anything
fundamentally bad if even rumors start
to spread that something at this Bank is
a little bit fishy you can imagine every
one of these banks customers showing up
when that news report hits and says give
us back our money and they'll say well I
can give you back 10% of your money the
other 90% has been lent out and that
won't just affect this Bank because as
soon as these people try to go get their
money and they're not able to see it
then the rest of the economy all the
other actors in it will say wow the
banking system isn't as solid as I
thought it was and so all of these other
banks and maybe there wasn't any news
report written about them and they
didn't do anything shady all of their
customers
going to start showing up and they're
going to say well you promised me that
my money is available on demand
well I'm demanding it right now and of
course they're not going to be able to
get it because their money their money
was being lent out it's a situation that
you have right here is called a run on
banks because you know manx lent out 90%
of the money and so really people cannot
get access to it and so you can imagine
this is a very very very bad situation
you can have major bank failures a lot
of lending starts to be the whole
banking system essentially has to unwind
in some way and you'd probably would
probably throw the economy as a whole
into something of a into something of a
of a of a downward spiral and so the way
that governments attempt to address this
issue is that they say in particular
it's usually the central bank because
it's say okay we will insure banks and
that's why you'll often see at the front
door of a bank you'll see FDIC which
means Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation which means that the Federal
Reserve is insuring that bank so for
whatever reason it's usually up to some
amount of deposits if one of these
scenarios happens and the bank does not
have the money on hand the Federal
Reserve will say okay you know what
we'll just we'll just make sure we'll
just make sure that you have the money
and it's not an easy process it takes
some time but eventually the Federal
Reserve will give them the money but
that by itself creates another problem
so that creates really the second
problem is bad bad incentive or
non-market non-market I would say
discipline bad incentives because in a
traditional system if I was giving my
money to someone and they were going to
go and lend it to someone else
I would really care how they're lending
that money I would really care how
they're managing their business
I would really kind of want transparency
in terms of what investments they're
making how safe they are etc etc but in
a situation where all of the banks have
this FDIC insurance they essentially are
they essentially are backstopped by the
government now all of a sudden when
customers go to the bank they're like
you know what I really don't care what
you do with my money I know that you
have FDIC banking so all I really care
about is if you if you have you know
cute kittens on your checkbooks and you
have a lot of ATMs
have very impressive looking buildings
and they really wouldn't scrutinize the
financials so you don't have that market
incentive anymore
for banks to say hey look we are good
shepherds of your money look at where
your assets are being spent we want the
market to scrutinize us on to whether we
are making good loans or we are making
bad loans the third problem the third
problem of fractional reserve lending is
that because of fractional reserve
lending you're giving the private
banking system a good deal of control
over the money supply if they lend more
so lending lending translates into into
more money in the money supply or the
other way around if lending were to go
away that would mean contraction of
money in the lending supply and the
problem with this is is when the economy
is weak when you have a let's say you
have a recession when you have a
recession standard monetary policy
arguments you would say well you want to
increase the money supply maybe you want
to lower interest rates so that people
will borrow and start to consume or
invest again so you want during a
recession you want more money but what's
going to happen and the central bank
tends to do that when they when it is
clear that it's in a recession the
central bank will attempt to print more
money but a fractional reserve lending
system that's only part of the money
supply equation you also have the
lending and when you're in a recession
lending lending cut goes back so this is
what you want so you want this and the
central bank might do it that is what
you want but the reality is in a
recession the banks are going to get
scared they're going to see a lot of
their loans going bad you're going to
have less lending less lending and
that's going to essentially have the
exact opposite effect of what you want
you're going to have less less and I
should put money in quotes because it
depends how you define money but you
have less money in circulation and the
opposite happens in the boom so the
economy is down and out in a recession
that's going to be even worse when that
lending dries up there's going to be
even less money in circulation it's
going to be even harder for people to
get access to capital and the opposite
true is in a boom in a boom and I'm
running out of real estate on my screen
in a boom when the economy is maybe is
well heated or maybe overheating as
central bank will start saying hey let
me take a little bit of that fuel out of
the fire so what you want what you want
is less money less money in a central
bank might do that by taking securities
it owns selling it in the open market
and then it takes that cash and it could
even discontinue that cash but then and
that's what a central bank would so the
central bank could actually act on this
but when a boom the banks get even more
confident they get less risk-averse or
their start understanding the risk and
so the reality is you have more lending
you have more lending so it essentially
puts more fuel which is more money more
money in the system and essentially
adding more fuels to the flame of an
economy that is already getting
overheated so a lot of times this
fractional reserve lending might create
might lead to the money creation process
going in the exact opposite direction of
that you wanted to go if you really
wanted to moderate the fluctuations in
the economy